the mayor doesn't want the barge the MP
doesn't want the barge why are you
putting the barge in Portland at the
beginning of the year I set out five
priorities for the British people one of
them is to stop the boats and we can't
have a situation we are collectively
spending six million pounds a day on
hotels for illegal Asylum speakers that
can't be right I said that I would do
everything I could to stop that and
reduce the pressure on our communities
from Asylum sneakers being in hotels and
that's what we're doing we're bringing
forward alternative sites like indeed
the barge that we've announced today
that will save us money and indeed
reduce pressure on hotels all part of
our plan to stop the boats we're also
putting through Parliament a new law
which will ensure that if you arrive
here illegally you will not have the
ability to stay we will be able to
detain you and then swiftly remove you
to your own country if it's safe or a
third alternative Third Country
alternative like Rwanda that's a
sensible approach to this problem it's
the fair approach to this problem I'm
determined to stop the boats and we'll
do everything I can to deliver on that